okay anything you've said no to yeah i
want to know what you'll say no to at
this point what's the prank that you
said no i'm not doing this are you
asking that because the last video i put
on my youtube channel is actually called
ten stunts i backed out of
no you didn't know that
guys go check out his youtube channel
turn this podcast off right now
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i just wanted to know one
the one that's uh well publicized was um
the toy car up the butt which i backed
out of what it's a little toy car when i
told my dad in 2002 he didn't say no
strongly enough
he said oh no
which was different i could hear the
disappointment in his voice and uh i
just thought i can't do that how big a
toy car
matchbox
you we couldn't say matchbox for uh you
wouldn't just put a matchbox car up your
butt yeah um it started out as a flip
phone
then
that wasn't logistically realistic so
they changed it to a matchbox car yeah
and uh and that's what where you said no
you took a hot load
but not a hot
i probably would have said no to
swallowing a hot load in 2002 as well
you got to understand this
the bar has consistently gone up and up
back then
in 2002 the bar was sufficiently low
that uh it was too much the porn star
was off insane
but that is what happens right it's like
you guys do these things and you have to
up it every single time so you can't do
the same pranks and now you're just
putting yourself in potential danger
pretty much yeah i mean my new tour
is uh it's called the bucket list tour
and good god did i raise the bar for
that yeah we saw the intro looks wild
yeah i mean the intro is not even like
particularly that was crazy i mean it's
crazy and it was expensive and i love a
good would you take a dick in the butt
ah man i don't want to give up my
creative
[Laughter]
i don't be serious
here's the thing about mike tell alex
because it will be more fun
not original though
the thing about my creative plans yeah
is that
i
i can be pretty comfortable about
leaking them out because nobody's doing
nobody's [ __ ] stealing my ideas so so
um
there's a whole community stealing that
idea to be honest yeah right well
i mean
now
i i wanna uh
sort of
paint a picture here like with the with
the bucket list right with the bucket
list yes i i got butt ass naked and
jacked off with another man strapped to
my back in an airplane actually managed
to simultaneously ejaculate as i was
falling out of an airplane that seemed
so fluffy
it was uh he came too it was happy he
did not come back that's too much
yeah i did i had a medical professional
in disguise administer stolen general
anesthesia drugs into my arm while i was
riding a bicycle
[ __ ] super illegal super funny
super awesome you know like the the
actual question were you worried about
that because you're sober that's kind of
that's the craziest part of it to me
right
it's uh it's very crazy yeah this guy's
a full-blown addict he's getting
anesthesia right i mean
most of the ideas on my bucket list were
old ones and and this idea for the the
general anesthesia and doing general
anesthesia
yeah i mean it is it's concerning
anything that he said
yeah he ate yeah
of this stunt oh this done yeah why not
you're right like it's the most
concerning thing for me as a sober guy
yeah but
the original idea on the bucket list was
um to
take on trophy hunters to
promote tranquilizer darts i thought
instead of killing animals these trophy
hunters could use tranquilizer darts not
kill them and so that inspired me to
come up with an idea to line up for a
foot race with one of my bros on your
mark get set they shoot tranquilizer
dogs into our butt cheeks and then we
sprint for distance so funny that's fine
whoever makes it super funny thank you
whoever makes it the farthest
is so funny
did you do that well my man scott
randolph who's just off camera right
over there i asked him to to find
somebody who has a tranquilizer dart gun
yeah and and in short order scott's good
yeah he tells me it's like maybe a day
or two later he says i got a guy in
alabama
and so we get on the phone with the guy
in alabama and he's like oh gung-ho he's
like yeah i got it you know
tiger king
for sure but i found out
that the drug in the darts
is ketamine you know how you hear about
kidney like horse drink water yeah you
know they talk about ketamine's horse
tranquilizers that's what it [ __ ] is
tranquilizer darts are ketamine and as
an addict i loved ketamine so much
so i'm like [ __ ] i can't do it but i was
in this like tug of war because my my
ambition was now directly at odds with
my recovery and i'm like i was going
crazy i'm just gonna [ __ ] do it
anyway yeah you know but thank god i
didn't yeah and before uh i lost my mind
it occurred to me that in sobriety now
14 years of sobriety i've uh
amazing since i got clean and sober i've
had untold and [ __ ] surgeries medical
procedures that knocked me out and i've
never relapsed after the general
anesthesia so to answer your question i
was concerned about it but much less so
about general anesthesia than ketamine
yeah yeah yeah who's the biggest [ __ ]
on jackass
like who's the guy that you always gotta
convince to do [ __ ] he's always
complaining he's always whining
i'm glad that you're not an instigator
[Laughter]
i think that i love you guys and jackass
okay thank you guys very much for all
the entertainment you're amazing
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um i think that youtube title
i i describe or i like to think of
like the characters in jackass kind of
like superheroes in that each guy has
his own super power
you know like for knoxville it's
absolutely bulls that is his super power
bulls bulls
he's just very uh comfortable in front
of animal balls
getting like knocked by like in a bowl
ring yeah like a bull fighter but so his
he stands in his
[Music]
his willingness to stand in front of a
bull
and let what will be
the most violent hit you've ever seen
spinning like a ragdoll yeah
on the last jackass movie yeah he
he uh got
stood in front of a ball got scooped and
sent into a a one and a half rotation
flip where he landed on his head yeah
got a brain hemorrhage
broken rib broken risk a red
wrist
and uh a concussion are you guys
blame bread and heal yeah
also
he had a brain bleed yeah and a
concussion yeah yeah are you at all
worried about you guys worried about
like ct and [ __ ] um do you think that's
what happened to bam
i always wondered that that it was just
concussions and like
i don't know i'm not a doctor but uh
actually
um i
i i don't i don't know i don't know with
that with the bam situation
and uh
but i'm [ __ ] worried about
knoxville's brain i've i i have been for
uh
you know like he's like if you saw the
first jackass movie when he got knocked
out by butter beans the way that he was
snoring when you get knocked out and
you're like snoring loudly like that's
not good for your brain yeah and it just
he's just knoxville's had way too many
of those yeah and certain people they
develop ct and certain people don't for
whatever reason right i asked tony hawk
yeah tony knows all about this he was on
the pod he was very happy i told you
about the test you can get yeah and it's
like uh
there's a test that you can take for
like a predisposition to have
alzheimer's disease and whether or not
you have that
is plays a big factor in whether you're
going to develop so i asked tony i was
like well
what the [ __ ] do you do if you the test
tells you
it's kind of late in the game now like i
don't want to i don't want to [ __ ]
you don't want to know i'm with you yeah
i'd rather not know yeah like what do
you get
what are they i said like what was your
plan if the if you were positive for the
test yeah yeah
before you get into jackass yeah
because what a shitty spot to be and oh
yeah i took the test and
i'm [ __ ]
goodbye guys no i really wondered that
when i saw this stuff happen with bam
and again like you know i remember
watching the cky and
2k videos which were phenomenal because
they were skate videos but they were
also the prank stuff and it was just
right it was the coolest thing i saw and
this was back and they were older but
this was back with
i'm 38. okay so this is cassette tapes
right so back in our day it wasn't like
here's this link it's right you have to
hand your friends a [ __ ] cassette
tape and be like trust me you got to
watch this and he sold like millions of
those those were viral as cassettes yeah
going viral back then it was super hard
it was unbelievable there was two things
i remember going viral back then it was
the old man in the winnebagos faces of
death was pretty good awesome
i heard about that that was the
inspiration for happier [ __ ]
yeah the old man in the winnebago was
good faces of death was great
and it was cky and i remember seeing
that group and that group was it was
[ __ ] hilarious and
and then i don't know something kind of
happened where it went from like fun
jovial silly to a little bit more dark
on on cky no no later in his career oh
right right right right right yeah
yeah
it's tough man it's tough and bam was so
goddamn genius because
in the world of skateboarding even a
die-hard skateboarder just couldn't sit
there and watch an entire hour of
nothing but skateboard without just
going crazy skateboard videos from the
beginning needed some kind of uh comic
relief something to break up the goddamn
monotony yeah yeah and i
i knew i wasn't that great at
skateboarding that was like initially
what brought me to the video camera but
i was like you know like i'm not gonna
be a [ __ ] pro skateboard i'm not that
good so i'm just gonna dedicate myself
to being that comic relief
so i started showing up in skateboard
videos
just not skating and and and i was
looking for the opportunity to be in
other people's skate videos meanwhile
bam
didn't give up on skateboarding did all
the comic relief made his own videos set
up his own distribution
he was so [ __ ] creative
so talented so entrepreneurial
so much younger better looking richer i
[ __ ] was so jealous
[Music]
[Applause]
you